- Hi everyone, welcome to
the Homeroom livestream
Sal here from Khan Academy.
We have a very exciting guest today,
Margaret Spellings former
Secretary of Education
of the United States
and CEO of Texas 2036.
But before we get to that,
I will get my standard announcements.
First of all, reminder that Khan Academy
is a not for profit organization.
We can only exist through
philanthropic donations.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about going
to Khan academy.org/donate.
I also want to give a special shout out
to several corporations
that have stepped up
when they appreciated how
many people were leaning
on Khan Academy during the COVID crisis
and continue to lean on Khan Academy
and that we were already
running at a deficit
and our costs were going up.
So Special thanks to Bank
of America, Google.org,
AT&T, fastly and Novartis
and the many other
supporters of Khan Academy,
but we still have a gap,
especially as we go into 2021.
So as much help as you can provide
is very much appreciated.
I also want to remind everyone
that you can get a version
of this live stream
wherever you get your podcasts
Homeroom with Sal, The podcast.
So with that, I'm excited to
introduce Secretary Spelling's.
- Hi Sal thanks for
everything that you do.
- No, thanks for joining us.
Obviously it's a day
where there's a lot going on in the world
but it looks like the election results
are kind of in a pause mode
so maybe it is a good time for us to chat.
- About something else, yeah.
- Exactly about something else.
So there's a ton to talk about it
and I want to encourage everyone watching
to put any questions you
have for secretary Spellings
or myself on the message boards,
we have team members
who will surface them,
and I'll try to get to
as many as possible.
But Margaret, there's I guess two things
I'd love to talk about.
Well, first of all, explain to all of us
what Texas 2036 is.
- Well, 2036 is the bicentennial of Texas,
our 200th birthday and we use that kind of
as a hook to try to get people
to think about the future.
What we're trying to do is put
what I call the sensible center together
to think long term about
the most important issues
that confront our state in the course,
those are education and health,
natural resources, infrastructure,
the way our government performs
justice and safety issues.
And we're trying to corral
people to focus on the future,
to think big, to think long term
and to use tons and tons of data,
the facts to inform our work.
- And is this like kind of
spawned by the government
or it's a separate kind of
industry, not for profit.
- It's a not for profit
organization really created
by the business community
it's a who's who of business
and civic leaders from around our state,
who want us to get out of
the tyranny of the urgent,
and think long term about
what our state will need.
We know Texas like California and Nevada,
the West where we operate,
is big and growing
and getting more diverse by the day,
we're getting older,
we're getting younger,
we have a great hand to
play with human capital
as our number one asset.
But we have to do a lot of things right
to make sure that we fulfill them
and leverage the possibility
that we have with
this vast number of talented
people we have in our state.
- Paint a picture for us
what is Texas 2036 look like
If y'all are successful?
- Well, we will have invested
in education and health,
we sadly lead the nation in the number
of uninsured, adults and children.
We have the health outcomes to show for it
we are dead last on things
like maternal mortality
and diabetes and obesity
and things like that
when it comes to health indicators.
Where we were once in the mid 30s,
on our national education,
report card and reading,
we have fallen to the low 40s on the nape
and reading and so we have work to do.
And it's gonna take vigilance
and attention by the business community.
It's gonna take resources,
but it's gonna take really
all of us understanding
that these are the
priorities for our state
and for our nation and
we have to attend to them
in the short term and over the long haul.
Rome wasn't built in a day.
- Absolutely, and putting your education
which is really, part of education 2036
and obviously, your experiences
as Secretary of Education,
Whoever is the next
administration, obviously,
we've had an, beyond
the healthcare crisis,
the economic crisis, we've
had an education crisis
because of distance learning and COVID.
One could argue we already had
an education crisis even before COVID.
If you were advising whoever
is going to be Secretary
of Education come January,
what would you encourage them to focus on
and how to approach it?
- Well, one of the things
I think is so critical,
and you've just said it, Sal is that,
our students have really lost ground.
And in some cases, we've lost the kids.
I mean, literally, our
enrollment in Texas is down 6%
those numbers hold up across the country.
We have probably two to
four million students
who were enrolled last
year and aren't this year,
mostly in the early grades
and pre-K programs in the like.
For those students that
are enrolled and learning,
we know that it's not as
productive as it once was,
obviously, with an inability
often to meet face to face
and engage with teachers and peers.
And so we really have to
confront learning loss,
we cannot afford to lose
this generation of kids.
And they are way behind overall,
especially our poor and minority students,
those students for whom
COVID has revealed,
really a incredible amount of inequity.
And so what I would do if I were advising
the next president, is to say,
and your tailor made for this Sal
we've got to think about how are we going
to get our students caught up
and how are you gonna use tutoring
and one-on-one coaching
and other interventions,
research based practices to
get those kids caught up.
Secondly, I would say we have
to have broadband, ubiquitous broadband
and devices everywhere, period.
And we need a national plan to do that,
obviously, states are
important in those discussions.
So those are two things
I would do right away.
- And actually, I'd also
love you to advise us
because your first point, actually,
it touches on both points.
But on that first point about
how do you fill in folks gaps,
do the necessary mediation so that
this year's damage doesn't last,
that's what we work on a
lot here at Khan Academy
but I'll be very open when I
think about interfacing it kind
of a governmental level,
especially the federal government,
it feels very intimidating.
How do you get these two worlds
to kind of work together?
Do you think there are
opportunities there?
- I sure do.
There are platforms like
AmeriCorps and City Year
and programs like that,
that could be built out
to engage a workforce if you will,
that can be engaged in
this tutoring and coaching.
We know, here's the problem.
Kids have have lost ground.
And second, we know we need
to intervene with them in safe ways.
Well, how do we do that?
Well, it's going to be one on
one engagement, often online,
sometimes in person, can be in person,
we could do that safely, potentially.
How do we get them trained?
And with research based practices,
how do we identify the kids
that need help the most?
And how do we use platforms
like AmeriCorps and others
to set sail and join hands
on this on this issue?
I think people, whether
they're retired people,
or university students, people want
to help our students catch up.
- And so you're kind of imagining a world
where AmeriCorps or maybe even
a broader kind of coalition
of volunteers are actually going in there
and providing the the one-on-one help,
that a lot of kids are going to,
arguably always needed,
but need even more now.
- Exactly, and I think we
have existing platforms
of both at the state and federal level
that can be deployed to do that.
We can pay some of these people,
maybe there are some that are volunteers.
What we know for sure,
is that these individuals will need skills
and training at a sophisticated level
to help kids get caught up, obviously,
it's easier to do and
with younger children,
then if you're trying
to help kids get caught up in calculus,
you have to know something
about calculus, like you Sal.
- No absolutely.
It's interesting, because
obviously, Khan Academy
is one layer where people can
get practice at their own time
and pace and fill in those gaps.
And one idea that your
your last comment just kind
of triggered in my mind is maybe working
with a lot of these groups,
so that they can be kind of a force
that engages a lot of these students
on platforms like Khan Academy,
but also the opportunity to do small group
or one-on-one tutoring.
There's a separate not for profit
that we've just spawned up
that I've just spawned up
it's separate from Khan Academy
called Schoolhouse.world,
which is focused on,
how do we pair students
for free with live tutoring.
So I'd love to talk to you off offline
about how all of these different pieces
can fit together on the digital divide,
which is kind of your second big point,
which I couldn't agree with more.
What do you think?
Well, first question,
why don't you think this was part of
maybe the first few rounds of stimulus,
it feels like a no brainer to me,
for 10 or $20 billion,
out of a trillion or two.
You could maybe solve this problem?
And do you have hopes that it will happen
in the next few rounds of stimulus?
- It's a complicated problem,
every state is different,
the provider community, the
private sector community
is different in each state,
whether they have attacked this through
some sort of a central
planning process or a hub
that varies all over the country.
So I know that we in Texas
are one of just six states
that don't have a plan,
which limits our ability
to draw down federal resources.
But when I ask why is that
it's because we're big,
we have a multitude of providers,
we have, not the bottom
of the Grand Canyon,
but the Rio Grande Valley,
I mean, very, very remote places.
And then, of course,
what we know for sure,
and you know this
is that in urban America, this
is an affordability issue.
It's not that the
infrastructure doesn't exist,
it's that folks can't afford
the hundreds of dollars,
often it is for those
high speed connections.
- And how would you
recommend we can solve this?
Is this something that does get solved
to the federal government level
you put in the stimulus
program or something else?
Or is it is this more
of a state level issue?
- I think it's going to
have to be a combination
of both, I mean, some federal policies,
some freeing up of options for states,
but states are fundamentally
going to have to attack it.
Obviously, we need additional resources
from the federal government,
we in the States cannot print money
for these sorts of things like they can.
But if we're gonna address it quickly,
it'll need to be a partnership.
- And as we go through this crisis,
obviously, a lot of sub optimal things,
we've talked about several of them,
a lot of kids might fall further behind
they've been disengaged,
do you see any potential silver linings
from what we're going through right now?
Or reasons for hope?
- Yeah, I used that same phrase
and Arne Duncan corrected me the other day
and said, these are not silver linings,
they're hard lessons.
And I agree with that.
But I do think there are some takeaways,
that in some learnings from this
one is, I think parents are
have a better understanding
of where their students are,
it's one thing to get a report
card home in the backpack
and it's a whole other thing
to see your child working
and struggling and maybe
not reading on grade level
or with the, needed math
skills, or whatever.
So I think parents have some
insights they didn't before.
Secondly, I think, we've
made much more progress
in technology, learning
and having our teachers,
yes, struggle with it,
but make progress and understand
how we could better maximize this tool.
Third, I think we're learning and seeing
that it can be a tool where customization
and embedded assessment
progress monitoring,
can be, standard operating procedure.
So I think there are something,
we're also learning that our human capital
can be deployed in more
efficient, smarter ways.
Maybe we need to have
the world's best lecturer
doing the teaching remotely,
while others are doing coaching
and one-on-one, meetings with parents
and families and students and the like.
So I think we are learning some things,
we're seeing a
proliferation of innovation,
and problem solving around the country.
And one thing I do think is missing
that I wish we would would do
is engage our universities to go establish
a research agenda so that
at the end of the day,
at the end of this big experiment,
we've learned some things about
what worked and what didn't.
- I love that last idea, because yeah,
there's always,
Universities always looking
for things to research,
and we have a massive
experiment going on right now.
- Yes we do.
- That seems worth study.
So getting a lot of questions
in from a social media
from YouTube Park Pal, is asking,
what's it like being
Secretary of Education?
What do Secretaries of Education do?
And yeah I'll just add to that question.
- It's a good question.
- We imagine, in other countries,
we would call it a Minister of Education.
What is the role?
How's it special in the
United States especially?
- Well, it's an important platform.
And I think, and I'll
leave to the audience,
how well it's been maximized
in this recent past.
But, if I were the Secretary of Education,
I would be gathering experts
from all of these fields,
mental health, technology,
disease control,
space utilization, I never called anybody
from the White House or from
the US Department of Education
and say, I need your help where
they didn't come in running.
And so I think it can be
a convener of expertise,
a proliferator of
information and practice.
It can be a great listening
agency as a department
as people are struggling with
and learning from what happens
so to use that bully pulpit
in really muscular ways,
is a big part of the job.
Secondly, it can be an
advocate for resources,
both within the administration
and in the Congress
and a translator of what's
happening around the country
and the solution provider,
so that the Congress can act.
And, I think we could do a
better job of doing that too,
especially on things like broadband,
what are the consequences
for not having broadband
in our schools, both in
terms of learning loss,
but in terms of health care and a lack
of economic connectedness and the like.
So it's basically an
information proliferator,
a listener and a gatherer of
expertise on the policy level.
And then secondly, and most importantly,
especially in higher education,
certainly in K12 too,
it is a distributor of native resources,
especially around issues of equity,
Title 1 schools,
financially needy students
in higher education and the like.
- On that last, on that kind
of policy, budgetary front,
where do you see the biggest levers?
If you were advising the next President,
where would you try to make
sure you see extra investment?
- Well, I think, one of
the things of course,
you would expect me to say this
as a strong advocate for assessment
and measurement and transparency,
that no child left behind, started,
and that was affirmed by the
Every Student Succeeds Act.
And that is that we have to,
we will not solve issues of equity
if we bury our heads in the
sand and stop caring enough
to find out, as I like to say.
So how do we think about
measurement accountability
and testing in this era?
What's appropriate?
How do we do it?
How do we collect data?
How do we still have that accountability?
We taxpayers are paying a big load
for educating our students.
And yes, these are challenging times,
but how might we think about
those issues going forward?
I'm a big, what gets measured
gets done kind of person.
And I think that's a major issue
before policymakers and educators now.
- And how do we thread that needle?
'Cause it makes tons of
sense, anytime someone says,
it's very popular to beat
up standardized assessment,
and I always say,
would you prefer non
standardized assessment?
Would you prefer no assessment?
Because it seems like you need it.
But, yeah, maybe some
people would agree with that
but it does seem like, it's
an interesting question
of how it is used, or how it is perceived.
There's a lot of debate right now,
at the college admissions
level around schools
going testing optional,
that may be out of
necessity, because of COVID.
But some, University of California system,
just like, literally said,
we will not consider ACTs or SATs.
How do you think this is going to evolve
and where do you think
it should evolve to?
- Well, what we know is
that no system is perfect.
And as you say, a lot of
higher ed institutions
are test optional.
Well, in my view, it's
just a matter of time,
before things that are less standardized,
less validated, more
subjective, come into question
about fairness,
discrimination, and whatnot.
So I like to think that,
what we need is a full
and complete picture,
of which standardized
measurement is a part
and certainly that's true
in K12 education as well.
Where I think we are getting,
and this is what technology will bring us
is embedded progress
monitoring along the way,
that gives teachers real time information,
so that they can tailor their instruction,
they can intervene with
students, along the way,
one of the things that
was, I guess, a flaw,
although, the industry was where
it was, back in those days,
the teachers didn't see
the value in assessment,
because it took too long
to get any information
to them that was useful.
And so I think technology
will help us solve those gaps.
Course correct and it'll
be better for kids,
it'll be better for teachers
and I hope that this high
stakes notion will die down,
it's real high stakes for students to lose
as much educational ground
as they're losing now.
- And explain the term progress monitoring
a little bit more.
It's a term for those
who were in education,
it's a term that's very
fashionable these days.
What does it mean to you?
- It means that you're
checking in on students
in a regular way, and course
correcting along the way.
So just like you when I was in
school back in the dark ages,
you had your weekly spelling check
or your weekly pop quiz or your,
so it's a regular assessment,
a low stakes embedded pop in
online that gives teachers
and students information
about where they are.
- In the way we imagined it is,
as you mentioned, could
be on a paper base,
it doesn't need technology.
But on something like Khan Academy,
every interaction is not just practice,
it's also an assessment, you can log it,
and we give the reports to teachers.
And if they can look at that
in real time, they can make
the appropriate interventions
and do that type of thing.
And to your point, in
that type of a world,
you don't have to have that,
you got one shot at this student,
and this is gonna be a grade
for the term depending on
how you do if you haven't
done so well the first go,
keep working on it, and not a big deal.
- Exactly, that's the
other thing that I think
is gonna be a silver
lining out of this is,
we are learning and we already knew this,
but we'll come to expect that,
education is more all a cart,
that some students are
gonna master something
in three months, some
it will take 13 months.
But that this customization,
because of the embedded
progress monitoring,
and because the use of technology coupled
with great educators
will really change this model, I hope.
- So, we talked a lot about 2036
from a Texas lens, but I'll
stay indexed on that year,
since that's a lot of focus of your life.
How do you think especially
the education world,
we talk a little bit how
Texas might be different 2036.
But how do you think education
needs to be different
or how do you think it will be different
if we go fast forward 15 or 16 years?
- I think we have to start
thinking more seriously
about how we use time, different from now,
the academic year has been blown up.
The Academic Calendar has been blown up.
And so how do we use our time in ways
that are more all a cart, my word,
and we have things like
stackable credentials,
and badging and proof of
mastery along a continuum.
And you just put that in your portfolio
or your backpack or whatever.
So that you're evidencing
your learning along the way.
I think one thing that I'm seeing,
and this is certainly
happening in higher education,
and certainly in the employer community,
brand is starting to matter much less,
the name of the institution on the top
of your diploma matters less now than,
can you code?
Can you think critically?
Can you write?
Can you, this, that, the other thing.
And I think we, in education
and organizations like yours Sal,
are going to have to help translate
does this person have a skill?
Does this person have this knowledge?
- No, you're absolutely, I mean,
I also share that dream that,
in the next 5, 10 15 years,
pathways are not based
on seat time, there's alternative pathways
they're based on competency
and you can kind of clutch
together your own experience,
and they can directly have
pathways to whatever folks want.
Just in the remaining time we have,
we have a lot of educators watching this,
we have a lot of parents,
we have a lot of students
any kind of thoughts
that you, any advice you'd have for them,
while as they tried to navigate their own
or their children's
education through COVID.
and then think about the future broadly.
- Well, I do think there's no harm,
whether you're a policymaker
in a state legislature,
or a mom or dad with a student
or a teacher, understanding,
how are we aligning our performance
with our use of resources.
And what I like to say is
we gotta put our money
where our mouths are,
we say it's important to
close the achievement gap
and to make sure that all
students reach a particular level.
That was the whole, genius,
if you will, behind No Child Left Behind,
and having those higher expectations
for all of our students
but we also have to resource
that issue, like we're real.
And so we need to be looking at well,
how do we deploy technology?
How do we deploy teachers?
I mean, our very best teachers working
in our most challenging settings,
do we have the right curriculum technology
supports interventions to
close the achievement gap?
So how do we think about
resources coupled with goals
and objectives for students and families?
And if you haven't, go find
out how your school is doing.
Obviously, those will be old data points
from last school year
but, this school year we ought
to be looking at, not
necessarily accountability based
on a test, but where are the kids?
How many minutes are they learning a day?
What are the outcomes?
We have to keep our eye on the ball
and care enough to find
out, as I like to say,
as opposed to kind of
this ostrich approach
of burying our heads in the sand
and hoping for the best.
- Yeah, yeah, don't be
afraid of the information.
Don't be afraid of the
message, so to speak.
- Exactly.
- Well, thank you so
much, Margaret, this was,
I guess I really enjoyed this
'cause a lot of what you said,
resonated very strongly with me.
But it's always great, especially
in times of crisis like this
to kind of, think about how
we could be doing things
and how we can come
out of this in a better
and better shape than we
maybe we even entered it.
So thank you so much.
- Don't waste the crisis, as they say.
- Don't waste the crisis.
Thank you, thank you for joining us.
- Thanks Sal, appreciate you.
- So thanks, everyone,
for joining today, as
always, or not always,
but especially today thank you.
It was a great conversation
with Secretary Spellings.
It's always great to talk
to national leaders who,
I think are really
thinking about the future
in a way that's going
to best serve students
and best serve teachers and parents
and thanks for joining
and, we got to stay tuned.
I'm also keeping track of
what's going on in the election.
That's the other
interesting thing going on
in everyone's lives right now.
But we will see you next week.
So please join us for
the next Homeroom
WhatsApp live stream then.
(logo wooshes)